hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to see the
book 3 finale since it's two episodes
combined this is going to be a top ten
video instead of like my normal top 5
and a lot of you still have big
questions about book 4 with all the
changes in the show moving to digitally
only don't worry they are finishing book
4 as we speak and it's also going to be
all digital but it is guaranteed no
official release date but planned for
next summer until we hear otherwise also
reminder the giveaway is going to
continue for another couple weeks all
you have to do to enter that is be
subscriber and leave a comment below but
it's basically like a once a week kind
of thing by the time I post my book for
predictions video I'll try to explain
what the rest of my bonus videos are
going to look like in the off season but
on to the important stuff let's try and
help each other through this so careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episodes yet but here are my top 10
moments number 10 Korra gives herself up
there are a whole lot of last airbender
parallels in the way that finale went
down korra making the hard choice to
turn herself in really reminded me of
this susan's comet part 2 moment you
know where Aang ran off to meditate and
then came to the conclusion that he
would have to kill Ozai which was
completely against all of his beliefs as
an airbender I kind of liked it at the
end all of things neither one ended up
killing their enemy but Korra makes that
choice not knowing if she'll survive
she's the gung-ho avatar which is like
the polar opposite of angle up dn't
avatar I feel like if any of you get
into arguments with your friends about
whether or not korra is selfish this
would be a really good scene to show
them as evidenced that she is not but
moving on to number nine Tenzin is
totally not dead this made me so happy
he's such a guiding force not just for
korra herself but for the series in
general losing him would be like losing
your compass in the South Pole
I feel like the only people that could
step in and fill that role if Tenzin
ever left the series would be Jinora or
Zuko based on the way the finale
presented her I would definitely say
that Jinora is the future I'll talk a
lot more about Jinora as I work my way
through this list just because she is
now like the most interesting character
in the series but number eight the big
double-cross this is one of the most
creative uses of waterbending I have
seen so far booktube pushed it further
than I'd ever seen it before that with
the water drills but mean law or grades
allow or however you want to think about
her push the limits of waterbending the
same way Zaheer push the limits of
airbending aside from Katara's crazy
healing powers I don't know you know
what the flying equivalent of
waterbending would be we've already seen
crazy powerful blood bending from Amon
avatar last airbender spent a lot of
time showcasing Katara special abilities
which I guess has kind of been what
minghua has been to book three like the
super evil version of Katara we actually
never got to see Katara in her prime
like as an adult waterbender so I guess
we'll never know who would have been
more powerful but number seven team
beifong takes down Puli one of the
coolest takedowns all season
metalbending her armor around her head
so the blast splattered her brains let
me know if you think that that was like
the most violent kill so far the earth
Queens death was slow agony so you know
maybe that was a little bit more
gruesome to watch but I feel like it was
implied that poles' death was the
grossest I was also really happy when
Zaheer confirmed he did kill the earth
Queen when every push scores father off
the cliff so confirmed no earth Queen in
book for as good as that is the earth
Kingdom is a complete shitstorm right
now like it is going to be one of the
big problems of book 4 for them to solve
that whole fight scene though was just
absolutely amazing the animation was
incredible there were a lot of specific
moments where I thought they pushed the
limits of the animation in just amazing
ways so I'll try and mention them as I
talk about each of the scenes Korra
fighting wall hanging up was also super
badass I would challenge any of you to
try and do that like tie your legs up
and then try to fight somebody
but number 6 holy zere can fly this
is where all the guru laghima stuff
started to make sense it was a literal
thing meaning the void was more of a
spiritual vacuum for emotion and earthly
attachment than some sort of like creepy
journey into death I liked it it was
like a really big callback to guru
Pathik trying to get avatar aang to let
go of earthly attachment with the
chakras I feel like the show presents
bending as being like a very separate
thing like the different forms of
bending but I wonder if at a certain
level they're all connected like energy
bending is different from other forms of
bending but you know what if they are
all just different forms of energy
bending like everyone is tending the
same garden just some focus on different
areas of it based on their personalities
that doesn't really take the line
turtles into account but let me know if
you think that book 4 is going to build
on all the new things we've learned
about bending science actually bending
science sounds like a really awesome
class that they should teach at a
university in Republic City like that
would be amazing just the science of
bending I thought that the Zaheer PI Lee
moment was really bittersweet in a nice
touch
despite him being completely looney
tunes I think his emotions for her were
completely genuine I don't think that he
was manipulating her
that Mike and Brian just needed that
scene to show that she was his earthly
attachment and once she was gone he just
let everything go and literally entered
the void did anyone else think that he
was walking on clouds whenever the
camera panned out and showed him for the
first time just for a sec I thought that
he would just walk away on the clouds
instead of flying away but his flight
animation was so amazing I really like
the way they captured the physics of how
an airbender would actually be moving
through the air I think what he was
doing was airbending himself like he
wasn't airbending the molecules around
him like a traditional Airbender would
but let me know if you have an alternate
interpretation this made me think a lot
about the sub bending this season
I feel like Jinora x' astral projection
was supposed to be the actual sub form
of airbending but did anyone else think
that so here's weightlessness was
actually the intended sub form that Mike
and Brian had been talking about I think
it's like earthbending you know having
two different sub form so now airbending
has the sub form of astral projection
and weightlessness which leads me to
number five Bolin is the lava bender I
think we all collectively felt like he
was gonna get a sub form this season I
actually thought it was gonna be metal
bending but I woulda liked it better if
ghazan had taught him how to do it I
guess I just wasn't quite enough time to
give them like their own story arc like
back during book 1 where Tenzin was
trying to teach Korra how to airbend he
had this really amazing lesson arc where
he was just teaching her about the
mechanics of airbending and I feel like
we didn't get that for a lava vetting
like I still don't understand the
mechanics of lava bending the wiki in
real life explains it in a cursory way
but I just like it when the show gets
really spiritual with the way it
explains bending I feel like the really
heartbreaking moment though from that
whole sequence with the lava was the
destruction of the northern air temple
it was like watching a priceless work of
art get destroyed you know you just
cringe oh just like Oh God even though
the air nomads are gonna be roaming
around I still think that at some point
they will rebuild that temple it seems
too important not to but moving out to
number 4 Zaheer tries to kill Korra in
the Avatar State I feel like we all
collectively were thinking of the last
airbender book 2 finale when we saw this
scene especially with all the green
crystals lying around the outcome was
essentially the same egg went into a
coma effectively rendering him inert
until book 3 and Korra is severely
disabled so there are a whole lot of
things inside that cave that I noticed
specifically you know not only all the
crazy faces in the morphing like the
really awesome anime sequence that they
took it to especially with the way
animated chorus face but I also noticed
that the Dai Li were working for the Red
Lotus which makes me wonder if the Red
Lotus use the Dai Li to guide the earth
Queens mistakes like they counseled her
to make decisions that would set the
earth Kingdom on a path to destruction
I'll talk more about that during my book
4 predictions video but I definitely
think there are more Red Lotus people
that we'll meet I actually didn't think
the core was going to die for a little
bit and whenever they animated her face
in that really anime way when her eyes
bugged out I went a little nuts
I feel like Studio Mir has done a really
good job of pushing Korra in a more
anime direction this year which makes me
feel like we'll see more scenes animated
in this way during book 4 Mike and Bryan
have already said that another studio is
helping finish book 4 but studio Mir is
animating pretty much every episode
they're just getting like a little bump
just because animating is such a time
intensive process but moving into top 3
now Korra is rescued by the airbenders
one of the coolest uses of bending all
season it reminds me that there are
still a lot of creative innovations in
bending that we haven't seen yet I'm
really interested to see if we see some
unusual fire bending in the Fire Nation
during book 4 let me know if you agree
but I feel like Jinora is air vacuum was
like a big callback to her saving raava
in the book 2 finale like Jinora has
made a big finale save two times in a
row now which makes me feel like Bryke
and Bryant are positioning her out front
for like a spin-off comic or at least
presenting her as the future of the
Avatar universe like for whenever they
stop telling Korra driven stories it's
like whenever they make Zuko the
protagonist of the search comic I feel
like we're just gonna see something like
that from Jinora but on to number 2
Korra versus Zaheer it reminded me a lot
of that Aang scene from book 1 when he
first learned that the air nation had
been massacred so he flipped out
hardcore it just went into the Avatar
state and no one could talk to him like
he was completely spaced out I feel like
since then last airbender and Korra have
done a really good job of explaining
some of the positives and negatives of
being in the Avatar State it's so
powerful that your conscious mind is
suppressed and you literally become a
force of nature so if you're not highly
trained the potential for collateral
damage is really high and you become
super vulnerable the whole battle scene
was an amazing call back to the sozin's
comet battle with some twists I mean
that was all I could think about
whenever they were flying around
fighting each other the big twist
obviously were that Korra was using
firebending to fly like Ozai and say
heroes using airbending like Aang and
then to call it back to a again whenever
beifong earth bended so here's prison it
was just like the scene where ever
took your cones bending and remember at
the end of both those big battles
neither Aang
nor Korra killed their enemy but finally
my favorite moment from the finale
obviously
Jinora is master ceremony I will freely
admit to crying a little maybe a lot
this is probably the best callback to
Last Airbender at least my favorite it
was like whenever n got his ceremony at
the end of book 1 he was accepting his
role as the avatar and here Jinora was
just accepting her role as the new
spiritual leader of the air nation just
to clarify I think Tenzin was saying
that she's basically going to be leading
the air nation and he'll just be
counseling her it's a huge payoff to the
father-daughter relationship story they
had this year it's him acknowledging her
abilities and maturity so I feel like
this season would be a great story arc
for any of you girls out there to watch
with your dads especially if you want to
get your parents into Avatar so I have
all kinds of thoughts about book 4 I'm
going to say that for my predictions
video which I'll try to get out tonight
just while it's all fresh in our heads
but let me know what were your favorite
moments from the finale and what was
like the first reaction you had after
finishing the episodes I think the first
thing I did was post a picture of Ann
crying like that was my immediate
reaction lots of crying overall I gave
both these episodes a solid A+ I feel
like this is the strongest Korra finale
so far I love the way they altered all
the characters I thought the narrative
was a lot more engaging and cohesive
than previous seasons - and they
continued to push the boundaries of
animation in the series just to explain
a little bit more about the animation
there was this really awesome podcast
that Mike and Bryan just did all add a
link for it in the description where
they basically talked about the
animation in the series the interview
was great but amongst the many things
that they talked about they explained
the way that they run their shows like
letting animators be animators based on
the style that they want for Korra for
example on most animated shows in the
United States the overseas animators are
really limited to what they can do like
they're not allowed to be real animators
or innovate or bring new ideas to the
table but Mike and Bryan have tried to
find a way to allow some of that
creativity back into the process mostly
by finding animators that can pull off
what they have in mind and allowing new
ideas during the animation process I
think that's why a lot of the beifong
flashbacks look so amazing they were
totally different animation style in the
normal core episodes and you would not
see that and like a typical animated
children's show I think it's a really
good example of the attention they give
to the creative process and
the best things overall about the avatar
series in general most of the feelings I
have about the series right now are
completely optimistic they were pretty
clear though that after book 4 they
would not be animating another avatar
series they'll be doing something just
not avatar speaking of which actually
one of the bonus videos that I'm playing
in the next couple of days is like a top
ten Mike and Bryan interview moments
from that podcast just because they go
into such a level of detail from behind
the scenes like what's going on with the
series what they felt about the avatar
movie it was so amazing the most
interesting thought that I'll leave you
guys with is it Mike and Bryan said that
because animation takes so long
they've already wrapped up everything
that you have big questions about any
hanging plotline or character you feel
got dropped like Azula for instance
they've all addressed it in future book
four episodes so you can feel happy
knowing that most of your biggest
questions will be answered during book 4
but I'll try to address a lot of the
specific ones during my predictions
video so I'll try and post that tonight
there's a whole lot of stuff going on
this weekend so I'll try to get
everything out as fast as possible but
right now you can click here to get that
predictions video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to get my next Korra Q&A
that might be Monday before I post that
video just quick heads up so thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
everybody go hook your sky bison because
we're all always the prime school inside